so i'm going to start and just kind of go over all the different mechanisms we have for targeting vcma
on plasma cells we have our different drug classes of five specific antibodies some of these are fda
approved in myeloma none of these are fda approved in amyloid though so there's a little trick to the
trade amongst all of us where there's a little subtitle within nccn about al amyloid being a
myeloma defending event and that's how we've been getting access to this in the real world
now there's going to be some studies and some real world evidence i'm going to go over here
in the next several slides we also have a tri-specific that is coming out now it's in
myeloma and study and hopefully one day we have an al arm to that as well then there's the antibody
drug conjugate so we all talked about toyotas and bottle teas and then talked about teslas so
basically everything on here in amyloid is a tesla but looking at the antibody drug conjugate which
i'm going to get to next here
you
it's somewhere between a model t and a toyota it works but it doesn't work that well
so this is looking at the european myeloma network study looking at
belen and methadone in relapsed refractory al we're going to go over everything here
in the relapsed refractory setting we have very little data on newly diagnosed al
so in model therapy they looked at giving this every six weeks up to eight cycles
they used male stage patients between uh cardiac one all the way up to 3a so you'll
notice the theme here most of the studies are shying away from adding the really sick patients
so you don't see anyone enrolling the three b's three c's 35 patients were included in this there
was a large portion of patients that had to discontinue for multiple reasons here primarily
disease progression some adverse events and some deaths that occurred to disease the median
progression on these patients as far as survival was not as good as what we would expect we were
getting somewhere around a response rate of 51 percent so that's even less than what we're seeing
with our current standard of care in newly diagnosed patients which is using their si board
d so in my opinion we can do much better than this especially if we're going to target bcma and amyloid
amyloid clones are heavily saturated with high expression levels of bcma
coming over to what is one of our several um what we're calling the teslas of amyloid
here so anything that is cell true cell therapy going after bcma and amyloid is going to get the
job done that is where this is all rapidly going is into the direction of bcma cell therapy for
al amyloid it's going to be a curative therapy for these patients this is a single arm phase
one two we had it open at our center along with several other centers uh this is going to be the
data i'm going to show on the next slide for the first 23 patients they have accrued all
40 patients so that data is going to come out at our next big meeting crs was in the same ballpark
what we're seeing with myeloma patients anytime we're talking about a bcma are at 78 percent
13 percent of those were grade one uh five percent grade two no icans or other neurotoxicity was
reported which is quite different than what we're seeing when we're talking about cell to cell
so this is looking at the responses here so you see here 96 percent of these patients actually had
complete normalization of their involved hematologic disease markers so in amyloid
one of our goals is to have a complete hematologic response very rapidly so when we're using these
bcma uh card t or on future slides we'll talk about some bcma by specifics
this this doesn't take a long time this takes weeks a couple weeks and we are getting these
patients to shut down amyloid production 17 of the 20 that were tested were mrd negative by day 25.
this is very impressive data this is the new um dual CAR-T that is out by alexion it targets cd19
and bcma so this is just going to go over study design here it is open it is enrolling it's in
the 1b phase looking at different dose adjustments we have this open as well the cool thing about
this is it's using a fast car technology the vein to vein time is only around 14 days
so we're going to look at that in just a few minutes and then we're going to talk a little bit
more about that in just a few minutes and then we're going to talk a little bit more about
this in just a few minutes so we're going to talk a little bit more about this in just a few minutes
and then we're going to talk a little bit more about this in just a few minutes and then we're
going to talk a little bit more about this in just a few minutes and then we're going to talk
a little bit more about this in just a few minutes and then we're going to talk a little bit more about
this in just a few minutes and then we're going to talk a little bit more about this in just a few
minutes and then we're going to talk a little bit more about this in just a few minutes and then we're
going to talk a little bit more about this in just a few minutes and then we're going to talk
about this in just a few minutes and then we're going to talk about this in just a few minutes and then we're going to talk
of course, all in the relapsed refractory setting, they do very well. Yes, they have a higher rate of
CRS than what we're seeing in the general population of care myeloma patients. And there
was one reported case here in this series of a patient who had an HLH syndrome that was related
to the CAR. Delayed neurotoxicity, only one patient had a report of delayed neurotox.
This is the overwhelming slide here, and this is going to become more overwhelming as we go
forward with BCMA and AL. This is all the ongoing studies in the relapsed refractory setting
of bispecific BCMA targeting. We have every player out there involved, and we're seeing
incredible responses with this. We're seeing near 100% response rates in these patients.
This is the answer. So what's next? We need studies focusing on BCMA and
earlier lines, including newly diagnosed patients. It is going to be curative for the vast majority
of our patients. We got to look beyond BCMA alone for those who do end up having a refractory clone
underlying. We don't know what percent of those patients exist. Looking at dual CAR,
looking at tri-specific combinations, emerging real-world evidence, including looking at
patients of special interest within AL population, looking at those who are on dialysis, looking at
those who do have cardiac stage 3B, 3C, looking at GI amyloid. Those patients are really tough to
treat. Trying to figure out better ways to manage that particular patient population. We talked a
lot about our myeloma patients and how many of them are excluded from cell therapy trials.
It's even higher rates of these patients that are excluded in amyloid.
Amending current clinical trials. So when we start, we start designing our trials.
You're looking at the safety and trying to really highly select the right patient.
Once we have enough safety efficacy data, I think we've come a long way on making amendments to be
more inclusive of real-world amyloid patients. Looking at long-term outcomes, the timing,
the duration of the hematologic response and the organ responses. There's also going to be a big
role for using fixed duration of the bispecifics in this patient population.
The smaller clone, it's less refractory. That's going to be the direction that we're going to end up in.